- Le milliardaire Jeff Bezos
a gagné son pari.
Après un décollage réussi
au Texas, sa fusée complètement
automatisée, donc sans pilote,
l'a transporté avec trois autres
passagers aux frontières
de l'espace.
- I love it!
- En tout, le vol aura duré
à peine 11 minutes, mais
l'homme le plus riche du monde a
visiblement apprécié
son expérience.
Le succès de Bezos et celui
du milliardaire Richard Branson,
il y a 10 jours, annoncent
la naissance d'une nouvelle
industrie : le tourisme spatial.
Aujourd'hui, les simples mortels
peuvent espérer mettre le pied
dans la cour des grands,
à 100 km d'altitude.
ROBERT LAMONTAGNE,
astrophysicien
- C'est ce qu'on appelle un vol
balistique, n'est-ce pas.
Vous montez très haut et ensuite
la gravité fait son travail,
elle vous ramène au sol.
On atteint l'espace, mais
on ne vole pas dans l'espace,
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne fait pas
le tour de la Terre.
- C'est l'arrivée à maturité
de plusieurs technologies, dont
celle du pilotage automatique,
qui a rendu cet exploit
possible.
ÉRIC LAURENDEAU, prof. Génie
aérospatial, Polytechnique Mtl
- Au fur et à mesure des années,
des expériences tant dans
les fusées, mais dans les avions
et même dans les voitures,
on commence à maîtriser
ces technologies et on fait
de plus en plus confiance
aux prises de décision
automatisées des ordinateurs.
- Jeff Bezos n'a pas encore
annoncé le coût d'un billet
sur les ailes sa compagnie.
Mais Virgin les propose
à 250 000 $ pièce.
Alors que Space X exige
50 millions $ pour chaque vol
orbital d'un astronaute
de la NASA. On ignore également
les conséquences sur
l'atmosphère terrestre de
la multiplication anticipée
des vols de fusée.
- Si on parle de centaines,
voire de milliers de vols
annuellement, et même peut-être
plus, on va peut-être faire face
à un problème environnemental
et aussi à un problème
d'acceptabilité sociale.
- Le même problème s'est posé
avec l'industrie aéronautique
dans le passé et les efforts de
recherche permettent maintenant
d'en diminuer les impacts.
- C'est des études qui vont
prendre du temps, mais je pense
pas que l'industrie va exploser
du jour au lendemain. Ça va
prendre encore des années avant
qu'elle devienne mature,
et les scientifiques seront là
pour l'accompagner.
(cris et applaudissements)
- Ici Normand Grondin,